Welcome back everyone this is my peacemaker deleted
scene video for that justice league deleted
scene in the finale with almost the entire dceu
justice league turns out they actually did film
a version of the scene with everyone there from
the justice league including batman and cyborg
so we'll break it down and james gunn himself
also spoke about it after the finale aired he
had some interesting things to say about what was
going on with batman and cyborg during that scene
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos they did confirm peacemaker
season 2 for next year i will be doing episode
videos for that just like i did for season 1.
real quick shout out to my friends at raid shadow
legends who asked to sponsor this video raid
shadow legends is one of the biggest mobile games
in the world right now that's totally free to play
that's right it's free they wanted me to tell you
about all the new champions they're introducing
new legendary champions like the archbishop
pinteri of the sacred order who's a hydra support
god with party buffs for accuracy blocking and
reducing healing requirements during encounters
recently raid has released its biggest baddest
scariest boss yet the hydra it's supposed to be
one of the toughest fights in the game but it's
absolutely worth it because you can get some of
the best artifacts from this boss this is the best
time to get started in raid and if you use my link
in the description below or scan the qr code
right here that i'll put on screen in the video
new players this month will get a free starter
pack worth almost 30 dollars to kick start your
game we're talking a free champion tyrell 200k
silver one experience boost one energy refill
and one ancient shard so you can summon an awesome
champion as soon as you get in game all that free
stuff they give you you can find in your inbox in
the upper right hand corner right here so click
that link to find out who you get but you've all
probably seen the justice league peacemaker scene
even if you haven't watched the series yet which
is kind of funny i think there were people posting
the clip of it to youtube like seconds after the
episode aired i was still working on my video and
i saw all these peacemaker clips up on youtube so
even if you live in a country where you're still
waiting to actually get the episodes legally wink
wink we know what's really going on you know james
gunn actually brought the legit justice league
in for a cameo scene it was all about paying off
that aquaman fish sex rumor from episode one when
he was in the hospital and throughout the rest of
the episodes up to the finale peacemaker every
once in a while would just have similar funny
conspiracy theories that he said he read on the
internet or on social media he starts fish let's
take it a step too far aquaman fish guy on twitter
works for the aquarium said for 50 bucks he brings
him in the back so he can have his way with a
sturgeon i refuse to believe that and i refuse
to believe that at pepe the frog 89 is lying to me
for no reason james gunn explained that peacemaker
is supposed to be such a summer child when it came
to the modern internet that he would automatically
assume anything he read online was 100 percent the
truth that's why the first time he talked about
this aquaman fish rumor he said someone on twitter
with the username pepe the frog told it to him
and anybody who's ever used the internet in the
last 10 years knows that that was a meme account
like pepe the frog the meme it was just some
random twitter user posting a joke about aquaman
but the even funnier thing i think is in the
finale the bigger twist is that after he came for
green arrow with those sick brony burns there was
a really hardcore green arrow burns stephen amell
also had some funny replies to that too but john
economos actually corroborated the aquaman rumor
no i actually heard that's true about green arrow
but that's the first thing he said that's real
an aquaman fish well yeah obviously the way
they play that at the end of the episode though
is that it is just a rumor like aquaman's like
i can't believe this i hate this rumor so much
screw you barry so i guess we have to assume
that john economos also kind of falls into
like these internet rabbit holes with conspiracy
theories and gets swept up in all this craziness
technically aquaman does not do that with fish
that's the whole idea but then john economos also
corroborated the green arrow rumor too so i think
it's up to you to decide whether or not dceu green
arrow really is a brony that does those really
crazy things at conventions but earlier in the
episode leota tells her mother amanda waller to
call the justice league because they don't think
they can handle the butterflies cow and instead
of playing it like a joke like you would expect
amanda waller legit calls them in and that is the
joke like oh we're actually doing it but they're
late they don't show up until after the action
and there's no ben affleck batman and no cyborg
standing there james gunn said the main reason why
they played it this way the justice league showing
up late instead of actually showing up to help
them was mostly because the budget for the show
just wasn't big enough for a giant justice league
snyder cut level action scene with the entire
justice league using all their powers fighting
all the butterflies in the cow at the same time
and when most of us were actually watching the
episode i think we all pretty much just assumed
no batman no cyborg because warner brothers
is in the middle of changing their version of
batman in the movies like they have a separate
universe matt reeves batman movie with robert
pattinson that shouldn't affect dceu batman stuff
because it is in a separate universe but then we
have the new dc eu batman after the flash movie
that's supposed to be michael keaton's batman
even though he's also from a separate universe
and theoretically shouldn't cause problems for
the logic of ben affleck's batman showing up
in a cameo scene here in the peacemaker episode
because this is taking place before the events of
the flash movie but then after the episode came
out james gunn said there were like 30 minutes of
deleted scenes of this justice league scene and as
some of you probably guessed some of those feature
versions of ben affleck's batman and cyborg
the actor who played dceu batman in this scene
posted about it on his instagram a couple days ago
surprise surprise i wonder if he's going
to get in big trouble for this probably not
but he was just thanking everyone how awesome it
was to play a version of batman even though his
version of the scene was cut and that only warner
brothers and james gunn himself knew why batman
and cyborg were cut from the scene quote unquote
now i haven't seen any actor for cyborg posting
something like this whoever was the stand-in for
cyborg during the scene but the stand-in for ben
affleck's batman makes it sound like cyborg was
there too with them and then this is what james
gunn says separately about batman and cyborg in
this scene he says you know i don't know if i can
like dot dot dot he kind of gets quiet for a
second there are reasons for it but i'm actually
uncertain i can say what those reasons are it
might have to do with future stuff trying to
explain why batman and cyborg were not there if he
filmed the version of this where they were there
obviously i think he's talking about the flash
movie and how they're gonna handle the multiverse
transition to michael keaton's batman from ben
affleck's batman and ray fischer is obviously
having issues with warner brothers in real life
right now and is not wanting to come back until
those are resolved so warner brothers sounds
like they basically told james gunn when he was
in the edit bay cutting the episode together
that he had to take out batman and cyborg
i don't know if they'd ever let him release the
deleted scene online maybe someday but probably
not till long after they figured out their new
version of the justice league in the movies
going forward right now the flash movie is coming
out this november after the black adam movie so
we'll get more flash trailers this summer and
more details on what's happening exactly with
ben affleck's batman during the movie he's playing
an important part in the movie i've already posted
a couple videos with scenes of him in the film but
at least for right now unless something changes in
the future ben affleck himself is billing it as
his final batman appearance in the movies and
michael keaton is beginning his tenure as the new
main batman that they use in all the crossovers
even though he is still technically from another
universe there's been a bunch of footage of him
recently in the batgirl movie but they haven't
completely explained which universe the batgirl
movie is taking place in whether that's in the
universe from the tim burton batman movies or
if that's taking place on the main earth of the dc
eu with the rest of the justice league characters
because in that movie gordon is being played by
the jk simmons version from the dceu he's going
to be barbara gordon's father so the continuity of
the batgirl movie is a little confusing right now
aquaman 2 is coming out in december but i'm not
expecting a ton of batman references in aquaman 2
and as for justice league during the black adam
movie most of that movie is about setting up the
justice society of the dc eu so they'll probably
just have some loose references to the justice
league like they'll be aware of what's going
on with the justice league during the film and
maybe maybe they'll have some kind of hint as to a
future where we see black adam versus a version of
superman because the rock really just seems like
he wants to do a movie with henry cavill superman
you know i always thought that it might be
cool to hang out with superman that would be
cool right i mean we're kind of similar in terms
of our powers our strengths our speeds because
look at the end of the day you never know
black adam and superman could become friends
or they won't who knows maybe we'll see but before
i go i want you guys to help me out with something
it's something that's pretty important i need
you guys to help me get a message out to uh
to some of the other ones some of the
other dc superheroes let's let flash shazam
aquaman wonder woman batman and superman let's let
them know something things will never be the same
because the hierarchy of power in
the dc universe is about to change
i don't know if there's going to be a henry
cavill superman cameo scene in black adam
it sounds like there is not just based on recent
rumors but that could always change it's really
easy to film cameo scenes like that on the fly
and the movie isn't coming out to this summer
i will post a link to my full peacemaker finale
video in the description below and all my other
peacemaker episodes the next big thing i'll
be doing episode videos for pretty soon will
be marvel's moon knight series you can click here
for that full black adam super bowl trailer video
and you can click here for my full doctor
strange multiverse of badness super bowl trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!